in the air and on the ground nelson  mandela's remains received full military  honors as they approach their final  resting place along the streets around  Mandela's home village locals came to  get a final glimpse of the man they call  the father of the nation celebrating  this legend earlier a memorial ceremony  was held at an Air Force Base outside  Pretoria Mandela's family friends and  members of the ruling African National  Congress paid their respects South  Africa's current president spoke of the  sheer range of Mandela's achievements so  many things have been said about Madiba  because he has done so many things he  has distinguished himself so many times  in everything you can think of Madiba  the man of action Mandela will finally  be laid to rest on Sunday it will be a  combination of state funeral with  military pomp and traditional ceremony  including the slaughtering of an ox and  salutations from the king of Mandela's  clan